hundreds of people have died in a train
crash in eastern India but what caused
it and why does so many incidents like
this happen here
there were three trains involved the
coromandel express which was headed to
the southern city of Chennai and the
howrah express which was due to reach
howrah and a stationary freight train
here at bahanaga Bazaar station there
are varying accounts of exactly which
Train derailed first but a railway
spokesman says he believes it was the
coromandel that came off the tracks
first
India has a long history of deadly
crashes with sometimes hundreds of
incidents every year it's a system under
pressure with 14 million people
traveling by train every day now the
government has been trying to make
improvements but there are still big
concerns around signaling issues about a
lack of collision devices being used
aging tracks a lack of Staff too but
this also comes at a time when the
government is trying to expand its
infrastructure and increase the number
of trains being made available to people
the Prime Minister Narendra Modi has
vowed to punish stringently anyone found
guilty and he said they're working
towards restoring the track by Wednesday
but restoring public faith in the safety
of the network well that could take much
longer